Oh
Motown Morrissey c'est une ville fantôme le
meurtre Kappa le d
tout le monde a un nom pour l'appeler pour moi c'est
juste Detroit l'endroit où je suis
né l'endroit où je vis Qui suis-je, je
m'appelle Je serais une mangue Henderson  Manoir
tout en cire, ils m'appellent mr.  jour
en anglais, un ghetto est un
groupe de personnes identiques qui
vivent au même endroit après la Seconde Guerre mondiale. Le
ghetto signifie un groupe de pauvres
gens vivant ensemble à
proximité et, dans cette mesure,
ce n'est même pas le cas.  cela signifie plus un groupe de
gens, cela signifie un groupe de noirs
vivant ensemble et dans de mauvaises
conditions sans espoir pour l'avenir
et aucune idée de comment y arriver, voilà à
quoi ressemble le ghetto, on
dirait une [ __ ] de bombe qui frappe tout
ça, les familles semblent parties.  parti parti parti parti
parti maintenant dis-moi
où d'autre peux-tu voir ça maintenant quand je
dis que je vis dans le ghetto je vis parmi
ces gens mon peuple mais je ne pense pas
beaucoup comme la plupart d'entre eux et je n'ai pas
le  mentalité de ghetto et nous pourrions et
j'ai eu plus d'opportunités que beaucoup
et c'est là que le truc de la classe entre
en jeu. Je n'ai aucune idée que mes
parents meurent de faim en rentrant ivres à la maison. Je ne suis au courant
d'aucune de ces choses parce que je
ne l'ai pas fait.  J'en fais l'expérience et c'est un
phénomène courant dans le ghetto quand j'étais
enfant. Je voulais un de ces
bâtiments. Je rêvais d'avoir un
de ces bâtiments et d'avoir un studio
ou peut-être très souvent l'un d'entre eux. J'étais un
enfant, vous
utilisiez  pour travailler ici les gens avaient tout
ça c'est du travail non rien à vendre à
louer
tout ça c'était le plan du premier étage oh
qui est sorti le premier qui a
fait faillite et ici même 200 000
personnes travaillaient ici et maintenant ils
n'ont plus  un enfant et c'est le
début encore une fois, j'ai grandi avec ma famille
très proche donc c'était un peu comme
grandir avec une couverture sur toi tout le
temps où nous étions dessus, nous n'étions pas riches mais
dans la famille qui travaillait très dur de ma famille
donc nous  nous avons survécu et vécu et il y avait
beaucoup d'amour dans la maison et cela m'a en quelque sorte
permis de poursuivre mes rêves
là où son couplet commence à demander hé
juste là oh alors ce que nous devons faire
maintenant, c'est créer une structure de chanson
Oh
d'accord maintenant ça  le magazine vient de oh
c'était dans ton courrier Jill ok mais il
dit quelque chose ici en japonais
expliquant la chose parce qu'il était vide et
une fois j'ai pensé qu'il avait été mangé mais tu peux
voir qu'il parlait de certaines personnes
malades Je suis entré dans le business de la musique à  à un
très jeune âge, ce n'était pas notre affaire, c'était
juste de la musique parce que c'était
toujours de la musique à la maison, euh, ma
grand-mère jouait toujours du piano, ma
mère, mon oncle chantait mon
père quand j'étais chez mon père,
il le faisait  jouer de la musique soul et de la musique jazz
et en arrière-plan donc dès que je me
souviens, j'ai aimé ça et dès que
j'ai pu me lever sur le tabouret du piano, je
jouais de la musique donc chaque année, il ajoutait
quelque chose que vous savez depuis qu'il était
petit, il  il dirait d'accord maman j'ai besoin d'une
boîte à rythmes j'ai besoin de n'importe quoi et la
première fois qu'il est allé au studio il a
dû embaucher quelqu'un pour faire le mixage
et c'est quoi cet homme de l'ingénieur il a
dit maman il a dit j'ai regardé cet homme
qu'il ne l'était pas  je fais autant et je ne
vais pas lui peindre tout cet argent pour venir
là-bas et il a dit que tout ce dont j'avais besoin, c'est de moi, c'est
tout ce dont j'ai besoin c'est d'un livre alors il a appelé
et a découvert où se trouvait le livre sur cette
machine que l'homme avait  utiliser l'
ingénieur utilisait et la prochaine fois qu'ils
avaient besoin d'ingénieur, il devait
ingénieur, je veux dire, je n'ai jamais vraiment raconté cette
partie, les ingénieurs parlaient
par-dessus ma tête parce que j'étais noir, vous
savez, ils comprendraient que je ne pouvais pas discuter,
donc  ils me diraient n'importe quoi s'il s'agissait d'
un client payant, ils ne leur auraient pas
expliqué comment concevoir, donc ils
parleraient par-dessus ma tête.
J'avais en fait une aptitude dans ce domaine, donc je l'ai
appris. J'ai appris à concevoir
très jeune.  et à l'âge de
16 ans, notre ingénieur du son et je suis un
jeune producteur de disques prometteur, donc je
suis content, je suis toujours content qu'il puisse faire de la
musique, je ne comprends toujours pas et je
ne vois pas comment quelqu'un  commence à faire de la
musique à la maison, puis à parcourir
le monde avec, c'est toujours un mystère
pour moi. Je n'ai jamais fait en sorte que notre journée soit consacrée au travail
pour moi parce qu'il était un peu maladroit,
il trébuchait sur ses pieds et j'avais
peur qu'il  il tomberait d'un toit et se
briserait le cou tu sais alors maintenant il
l'a fait dans sa musique non non tu vas dans le
mauvais sens, c'est qu'on reste fermé, idiot,
mets-le juste sur toi, là-dedans,
j'ai grandi dans la maison en voyant mon
grand-père a pris ses propres décisions donc je savais que
c'était que je savais que c'était une option
avoir ta propre entreprise c'est définitivement
une option je ne pense pas que je ne
l'ai jamais envisagé comme si j'allais être comme grand-père et avoir
ma propre entreprise je savais juste que je
Je n'étais pas obligé de travailler si je ne le voulais pas,
mais en même temps, mon grand-père m'a
toujours inculqué que j'avais toujours
un foyer, donc même si j'échouais, j'avais
un endroit où aller, donc je n'ai jamais eu peur
d'échouer, ce qui  m'a permis de réaliser mes
rêves,
sinon là-bas, pas trop mal aujourd'hui, pas de
pluie prévue pour la première fois depuis
quelques jours, ciel ensoleillé tout l'
après-midi et températures attendues
jusqu'au milieu des années 70.
J'ai divorcé avec la
mère de Sydney et  pendant ce temps, je
ne savais pas si j'allais
partir, tu sais, quitter totalement sa
mère alors j'ai fait et puis j'ai fait cette
musique,
c'est plutôt doux et un peu déprimant
au début et puis ça progresse
au milieu et puis  c'est toute cette
voix aiguë qui m'a un peu
rappelé des cris mais en gros
la chanson de Sydney et je l'ai appelée la chanson
de Sydney et je m'excuse de me voir
avant le premier refrain, c'est quelque chose que
je suis le seul à entendre et maintenant je te l'ai dit
que tu attendais pour avoir quitté
sa mère, donc à bien des égards, la
chanson de Sydney était une libération, c'est ce que j'avais l'habitude
de pouvoir quitter ce
mariage
Oh
Oh,
devrais-tu le faire aujourd'hui et
juste étudier oh  ok, très bien, étudie
ce que nous allons faire, ce que je suppose, vas-y, eh
bien, je suppose que tu travailles peut-être sur les
paroles du Seigneur, signe la boîte vide, très
bien, combien as-tu étudié ce que
tu veux dire, ça ne marchera tout simplement pas, non, je devais dire
tout ça, Sydney m'a fait
tout changer dans ma vie, j'ai dû changer ma
vie à l'envers et maintenant je suis tellement habitué à
elle ou à son système, tu sais, je
ne pouvais pas imaginer une autre façon de vivre
Sparrow plus haut huit ig8 H es  Je suis le
plus lent le plus lent EST le plus heureux h egg PP
J'utilise plus haut dans un sens Je suis plus haut
que toi tu fais mieux d'utiliser plus haut dans un
sens cela montre que tu connais le
sens du monde
tu n'utilises que des décisions plus élevées pour t'obtenir
un exemple ok notre appartement est plus haut
que les gens qui marchent dans la rue
maintenant tu utilises plus haut dans une phrase qui
montre que tu sais ce que ça veut dire plus haut
le ciel est plus haut que les appartements oh
c'était un peu du plagiat sur ce que
je faisais mais je  Je comprends qu'il y a
tellement de choses qui lui arrivent même à sept huit
ans, c'est tellement de choses qui lui arrivent
alors elle essaie de tout traiter et d'
agir en conséquence et la façon dont vous agissez
en conséquence est d'agir comme les autres
enfants maintenant le problème avec  c'est
que les autres enfants pourraient ne pas
agir de la manière dont cela va
réussir pour eux à l'avenir et
ces choses-là, c'est ce que j'essaie d'enseigner à
Sydney et vous savez, j'essaie de
lui inculquer l'amour de la lecture, euh, l'amour de
connaissances pour apprendre pourquoi certaines choses
sont telles qu'elles sont afin qu'elle puisse
les comprendre, au-delà du simple fait de
mémoriser certains faits et de les purger, donc
si vous savez, ce sont les choses que j'essaie
vraiment de lui apprendre plus que
tout et la compassion, vous savez  les gens
ne s'en soucient plus les uns les autres oui, mon
amour, hé
e Oh
toi
ici à Detroit, c'est l'avenue est l'un des
endroits les plus racistes des États-Unis,
je pense parce que les gens sont pour la plupart
plus ségrégués que la ville de Livonie
qui est  l'une des villes les plus blanches des
États-Unis et Détroit étant l'une
des séries les plus noires, je pense que c'est
comme les deuxième et troisième plus grands noirs
vus aux États-Unis, ils sont l'un
à côté de l'autre, donc le problème avec
ça à chaque fois que vous avez  un peuple qui
ne connaît pas les autres, vous n'avez
eu aucun contact avec les noirs, sauf
en les regardant à la télévision ou si
vous n'avez aucun contact avec des blancs ou
des mexicains ou qui que ce soit en dehors de
la télévision, cela engendre le racisme et
c'est ce que nous avons  ici et ce n'est pas du
racisme manifeste comme vous l'avez vu dans les années 60,
c'est plutôt une attitude, j'ai l'impression de savoir
ce que vous faites, je sais que vous ne
m'aimez pas parce que je vous connais parce que je
connais tous les hommes blancs à la télévision,
hé, quel est son nom
submerge une entreprise en pleine croissance, je l'ai vue
grandir depuis le sous-sol de notre
maison familiale jusqu'à l'endroit où il se trouve maintenant et
tout cela était dû à Mike et à plusieurs
autres, vous savez, ils croyaient
avant tout à la musique, mais ensuite ils se
dirigeraient eux-mêmes  et ils ont vraiment
travaillé dur pour faire des choses ce qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui, donc la fusion est un bon exemple de la façon
dont les gens sont de différentes nationalités, d'
horizons différents, d'âges différents, de
philosophies différentes, de
religions différentes peuvent se réunir et faire
quelque chose de positif, ouais, certainement, je
pense que cela vous parle.  quel que soit le
groupe de personnes qui est mis de côté, il s'agit d'une
discrimination et non d'une chose personnelle,
ils ont mis cela de côté, je crois qu'ils pourraient
faire tout ce qu'ils désirent faire, hein,
écoutez, je comprends cela, mais nous voulions
imprimer avec cette dame pour que vous sachiez que
ce serait le cas.  être quelque chose que vous
savez mais nous ne pouvons pas y remédier sans
dépenses supplémentaires pour nous, vous voyez ce que je
dis, très bien, c'est cool, je peux, je peux
vivre sans, je peux vivre sans buisson, je
peux vivre avec notre réponse Bible, mais vous
savez que vous ne le faites pas.  Je ne me soucie pas du ministre
Louis Farrakhan, je pense qu'il est drôle,
ok, nous avons perdu, nous avons perdu, nous avons perdu, nous avons perdu et nous avons perdu pour
courir principalement parce que les buissons sont au courant de cela,
je devrais répondre à mes mains, le
président ne peut être sur aucune œuvre d'art mais
il n'y a pas de président.  Je dis que mec
tu aurais pu mettre comme George
Washington parce que sa marque oui donc
nous avons besoin d'un générique sur tableau noir
immergé a été
créée en 91 par Michael Banks et
Krista Robinson donc Mike a eu l'idée d'
unir toutes les activités pressantes de
Detroit et une unité qu'il  Je l'ai appelé
submergé parce que c'est de la musique underground
et alors ils ont commencé à payer
l'usine de pressage qui expédiait les disques
aux distributeurs et cela a impliqué à partir de là,
c'est à ce moment-là que je me suis impliqué et
Michael a toujours été amis depuis
le début des années 90 et nous sommes donc restés en contact.
et c'était une situation où nous pouvions nous
réunir pour des affaires et
c'est à ce moment-là que je me suis impliqué dans
la réorganisation de Submerged, vous savez, j'y ai apporté ma
touche, donc
nous avons restauré ce bâtiment à partir de ce que vous
pourriez considérer comme un état de délabrement, c'était
une route difficile, vous savez, tout le monde
est vraiment très content du travail que nous
avons fait et ils ont été surpris de voir que
certains chats comme nous étaient capables de réaliser une
chose comme celle-ci. En fait,
ils ont fait des blagues sur nous et ce qu'ils
ne font pas, ils nous appellent ensemble.  groupe
aux ingénieurs du ghetto ouais moyen d'avoir nos
ingénieurs il est honnête je n'écoutais pas j'ai
eu le show
si bon
Oh
regarde
hé Frankie Amy ces deux disques mec oh
c'est bien ça a l'air vraiment bien c'est
juste le premier nouveau ouais ouais tournons-nous
ouais  ça a l'air bien je ne pensais pas que tu te
souviens de toi, tu es comme je veux entendre ce
que le disque avec le poêle Armani
ne bombarde pas l'esprit ici immergé est
vraiment bon c'est fondamentalement nous sommes tous une
famille même si nous venons tous de nous
pouvons  Il n'y a pas tous les gars réunis entre
Mike et Krista et euh tout le monde que
vous connaissez de la région de Détroit
mais nous sommes tous comme une famille qui travaille
pour laquelle tout le monde travaille ici pour l'
amour de travailler ici vous voyez ce que je veux dire
et la sphère dans laquelle il s'agit  tout va bien, nous nous
entraidons tous et c'est un bon
endroit pour travailler, mec, c'est un bon environnement, une
communauté, vous savez, revenez au bon vieux temps,
ok ouais, nous étions les uns sur les
autres, alors ils écoutaient
le mixage.  juste sous ce
ministère demain, que
voyez-vous ou vous savez ici avec le
rez-de-chaussée, je ne vous entends pas, je pensais que c'était
le bombardier furtif Octonauts,
vous êtes comme la musique, ok, eh bien, il y
a eu beaucoup de musique populaire qui
vient de Détroit  au fil des années, je
parie que vous connaissez tous la Motown,
certains d'entre vous le savent bien, c'était avant
votre naissance, mais c'est un autre type
de musique qui est originaire de Détroit et
qui est né au cours des 20 à 25 dernières
années environ, Motown Records  était le
plus grand succès de son époque et
je ne sais pas, peut-être la
maison de disques la plus prospère jamais exploitée par des groupes noirs.
Ils ont battu numéro un après
coup numéro un, je veux dire, ils devaient signifier la
plus grande chose qui ait jamais existé pour la musique soul en
étant motown.  fondé et à Détroit par
les Détroitois et les catalyseurs étant à
Détroit avec les talents de Détroit, le
système serait resté, mais le
fait est que ce sont des décisions commerciales et
des choses qui se sont produites qui ont
déraciné notre industrie d'ici et c'est parti,
c'est parti quand  huit quand
ils l'ont quitté, cela leur est parti lorsque l'
industrie a changé, vous dites techno, d'accord,
combien d'entre vous sont familiers avec
le son techno, n'est-ce pas,
le musée historique de Détroit était une
idée plus large pour une exposition historique sur la techno de Détroit
et c'est donc bon pour
les écoliers.  voyez que ce sont tous
ces gars en décembre qui sont allés dans les mêmes
écoles où ils sont allés, ont grandi dans les mêmes
rues, qui parcourent le monde et
qui font toutes ces
choses merveilleuses et font cette musique à partir de
rien et ont toutes ces affaires et tout ça
je pense que c'est excitant pour
un enfant de voir, tu sais, si je n'avais pas été
un enfant, ils avaient vu l'exposition techno, j'aurais
peut-être eu l'esprit très
différent si vous regardez la scène
ici, vous pouvez voir combien  des gens
du monde entier viennent
profiter du festival techno qui se tient
chaque année à Hart Plaza et, comme je l'ai dit,
il aura lieu ce week-end. Vous
avez de nombreux artistes différents et de
nombreuses occasions différentes d'entendre
les créateurs de la techno.  le son, je peux
m'immerger dans la motown dans le sens où un
gars sur le boulevard peut marcher dans la
rue, apporter notre sonnette et
avoir une opportunité, vous savez, et avoir une
chance de faire n'importe quoi pour
avoir son contrat d'enregistrement et faire signer son label
pour obtenir une distribution ou signer un livre et
un accord et circuler dans le
monde entier du DJ, vous savez que ces
services professionnels
lui sont plus disponibles qu'ils ne l'étaient auparavant, car
quand vous savez, quand j'ai commencé,
je ne pouvais nulle part  Je suis très fier
de faire partie de quelque chose qui offre
tant d'opportunités aux gens que vous connaissez
certainement.
Brandon Calloway chez lui, il a en fait réalisé
la meilleure démo que j'ai jamais entendue
et j'ai immédiatement dit que je voulais
les signer.  je dois les rencontrer et euh il est venu
au studio et il avait 18 ans 18
et 19 ans quelque chose comme ça euh vert je suis lui euh
il n'était allé nulle part il n'a rien
fait tu sais rien il
venait de sortir  au lycée et tout, il avait
juste l'impression de raccrocher au studio, alors euh
et d'une certaine manière, j'ai adopté Brandon, tu
sais, c'est comme mon petit frère, un autre
petit frère et donc il était avec
moi depuis, c'est comme ça que nous passons du
jour  un et bien, nous avons surtout Brian,
lequel la boit mal oh je marche avec tu
sais donne-moi du lait et des biscuits avec du
lait et des biscuits hahaha
heureusement du lait et des biscuits je ne pouvais pas
croire que les chips ahoy là et le lait cette
vraie merde et ensuite rien sur
homme à problèmes va te faire [ __ ] oh cool bag boho fais
la traite cool tu sais qu'il est vraiment
proche de moi tu sais qu'il aime que
j'ai des frères de feu mais il aime un autre
grand frère que moi tu sais qu'il
m'a montré beaucoup de choses sur la vie et la musique alors
bon après-midi  vous écoutez 90,9
FM avec DTR Detroit juste une
annonce rapide d'un avertissement d'orage émis
pour le comté de Macomb et qui est émis
jusqu'à 753, c'est 90,9 FM avec DTR Detroit
tout nouveau morceau de ces
gens merveilleux là-bas à Submerge, le morceau
s'appelle Do It  pour ça, fais-le Team sunspot
non, fais-le pour qu'il nous débarrasse-nous de tu sais, allons en
parler, allons-y, allons-y,
vous
45,
vous,
la plupart des musiciens, je sais qu'ils ont de
bons moyens de subsistance, ils aiment ce qu'ils font, ils
font le  le genre de musique qu'ils aiment
faire ils n'ont pas une grande maison de disques
derrière eux qui leur disent le genre de musique
à faire ou leur disent où aller ou
jouent un concert qu'ils n'aiment pas jouer
ils le font exactement ce qu'ils veulent  pour
ce faire, ils vivent dans leurs rêves à travers une
avenue que moi et mes partenaires avons tracée
donc j'en suis content ouais mais la plupart des
musiciens doivent trouver un travail, un vrai travail
et faire de la musique comme hobby ackerman quand j'étais
petit, c'était le  Dans les années 80, c'était vraiment fou
ici, avec ses trucs de dopage, alors j'ai
levé les yeux, j'ai vu beaucoup d'
argent sur la scène, beaucoup de gens se faisaient
tirer dessus et tout ça, mais je ne voulais pas
suivre cette route, j'ai toujours eu un  J'adore la
musique depuis que je suis petit, donc je m'en suis toujours
tenu à cela quand je me suis tourné vers elle quand je
suis devenu adolescent. J'ai eu des platines,
puis à partir de là, j'ai commencé à produire et
je m'en tiens à la musique, c'est ce que j'aime
faire mais certaines personnes pourraient aimer  jouez au
basket, tout le monde n'est pas dans la
merde sauvage, mais vous avez quelque chose qui est
dans la merde sauvage et ils
font n'importe quoi ici, je ne leur en veux pas
parce que j'ai juste l'air de l'avoir dit
avant, c'est comme ça qu'ils écrivent, c'est ce qu'ils ont
vu et  tu sais que je dis parfois
et je ne sais même pas que tu fais ton
propre choix à ce moment-là parce que si tu as
vu ça tout le temps et c'est tout ce que tu
sais, c'est ce que tu vas faire si
tu es là tout le temps  tu vas
à l'école ta mère à la maison ivre en fumant du
crack ou quoi que ce soit tu vas le vendre
ou faire la même chose donc mais il y a beaucoup
de gens qui font beaucoup de choses positives
ici aussi tu sais n'importe quoi parce que je
reste en dehors de ça je  fais mon truc tu sais
et j'aime juste m'en tenir à la musique, la
vie d'homme c'est quand tu regardes les dernières nouvelles
et aux dernières nouvelles tu entends des
nouvelles déchirantes et chaque jour les
dernières nouvelles ne changent pas grand homme fait
petit homme vérifiant ce changement vérifiant
ceci  changez alors peut-être en vérifiant cette
marque, ils disent que les rues sont dures maintenant,
le sol et se tiennent debout, mais à qui la faute
et je bouge, une grosse bombe a explosé
et six soldats ont été abattus, cette guerre est
insensée et elle doit être arrêtée encore nous
xing nous-mêmes par deux  des flics se sont fait tirer dessus ou
pourquoi l'a-t-il fait, c'est qu'il a
influencé mentalement de jeunes chiots noirs et blancs
qui évacuaient le liquide et aux informations, un
grand bar de maison s'est effondré quand ils ont creusé dans
les cendres, cinq enfants ont été trouvés à cause
d'un radiateur parce qu'ils ne l'avaient pas fait.  Je n'ai pas de
prix du gaz de chauffage exorbitants, c'est pour moi
et mon travail, je ne peux même pas avoir un jour
de congé, mais cette journaliste parle de
licenciements dans toute la ville, l'endroit est en
séries éliminatoires, s'en tient aux vrais trucs, petite
fille frappée par un gros  Le camion Marshall Fields,
c'est la vie,
imaginez qu'être issu d'un monde
bien déposé
était un mode de vie, à
bientôt, merci de vous montrer à la hauteur si
sans cela, comme wow et
ils louent
bien amen,
oh rien n'est vrai, vous êtes un mur, vous
devez y renoncer.  pour que tu ne fasses pas
d'autres gaz sur la plage,
ton cœur,
j'avais 16 ans, j'allais avoir 17 ans et c'était une
expérience que je porte avec moi pour le
reste de ma vie parce que le simple fait de voir
les choses que j'ai vues était euh, c'était
traumatisant de dire le  au moins parce que, euh,
vous savez, on s'attendrait à ce que ce genre
de chose ne se passe que dans les films,
mais j'ai en fait vécu à travers les chars qui
montaient et descendaient la rue, la
Garde nationale tirait sur des
gens qui mouraient dans les rues, des gens qui ne faisaient que
brûler et piluler  mon
ami pilule juste en train d'aller et juste dans la ville
c'était un pandémonium et les épidémies qui ont
suivi qui n'ont pas eu une exposition nationale ou
internationale comme l'émeute l'a fait,
mais en fait étaient, sinon plus graves, aussi
graves que l'émeute l'était, je ne pense pas que
le  l'émeute qui s'est produite en 67 pourrait se
reproduire personnellement parce que je pense que je pense
vraiment que les noirs, même les
noirs pauvres, se sentent généralement
responsabilisés dans l'entre-deux.
en volant
par une sorte de moyen, ils
vont surmonter d'une manière ou d'une autre
individuellement, ils ne le regardent pas, je
ne pense pas que ce soit autant un
esprit de communauté qu'à cette époque et
il faut absolument avoir un
esprit communautaire pour se rendre aux émeutes, donc je ne pense pas que
cela se reproduise parce que je pense que
les gens ont trop une
attitude individuelle, vous savez, ce serait plus un
individu qui s'énerve et fait
quelque chose de fou qu'un groupe de personnes
ou le  toute la communauté parce que je ne
pense pas que nous nous identifions plus en tant que
communauté dans nos cœurs,
regarde-toi, fille, je
n'irai pas de l'avant, vous avez tous des
trucs que je vais vous frapper, moi, l'histoire
est une blague, je  Je veux dire, quand vous commencez à
parler d'événements, les événements noirs, c'est l'
histoire des Noirs, ça n'existe pas, vous
savez, c'est comme si c'était comme un Sasquatch ou
quelque chose comme ça, ça n'arrive tout simplement pas, donc non,
nous n'avons pas entendu parler des émeutes dans
l'histoire. J'en apprends plus sur les émeutes.  en
écoutant mes parents, mes grands-parents
en parler, j'ai appris dans les
livres d'histoire que l'éducation n'est pas encore
importante, mais plus importante que
l'éducation, c'est comprendre et apprendre
à apprendre. Les gens prennent simplement
tout ce que cette chronique
leur lance à la télévision dans les médias et ils ne
le font pas.  Je ne veux pas l'apprendre, donc je pense que la
maison doit être améliorée pour que les choses
s'améliorent, les gens doivent prêter plus
d'attention à leurs enfants.
Pour moi, Detroit est une ville que vous connaissez. Je
ne pense pas que ce soit un début ou un début.
Je sais que ça a commencé quelque part, peut-être que ça
arrivera à un certain endroit, mais c'est en cours, c'est
un changement et cela dit une sorte d'
évolution constante, vous savez, vers une chose ou
une autre, oh, je vois les choses comme étant plus
ouvertes qu'à
l'époque où  Je disais que peut-être 657, le retour de
la graine va être lent et progressif.
Je crois qu'elle
reviendra. Je ne pense pas qu'elle
reviendra de la même manière. Je pense que
ce qui m'intéresse le plus alors  l'
extérieur de Détroit tel qu'il
était serait que l'attitude des gens
change. Vous savez, si cela peut arriver,
vous pouvez toujours peindre une
maison, mais si l'intérieur est brûlé, à quel point
est-ce bon?
Oh,
je pourrais certainement vivre dehors.  de
Détroit mais je ne pouvais pas donner deux pères
à Détroit parce que ma famille ne m'entendait pas trop loin,
il y a beaucoup de talent ici donc cela pourrait être
mauvais pour mes affaires de déménager
ailleurs, donc vous savez, il y a beaucoup de
facteurs à prendre en compte  garde-moi à Détroit, tu sais,
cette ville est certainement l'endroit où se trouve mon cœur
et la place de mon âme, je ne
la changerais pour rien au monde